John: 1, 2, 3!
Crowd: Good morning Hank!
It's... well, if yesterday was Thursday, and
the day before yesterday was Thursday, then
today must be... Thursday?
Crowd: It's Friday!
Oh, okay, it's Friday, it's Friday, January
26th. Thanks to the George Bruce Branch of
the New York Public Library for participating.
Let's get right to the survey.
Puppet: Describe a perfect day.
John: I wake up in the morning, write four
thousand words, Sarah comes home from school,
we have a sushi dinner together, and then
we read until it's time to go to bed. Oh,
and The Office is on, and I watch The Office,
and Pam and Jim hook up. YES!
Puppet: Assuming... I don't remember the words.
Assuming all things come to an end, how will
humans go extinct?
John: Puppet, I'm with T.S. Elliot on this
one; "Not with a bang, but with a whimper."
Puppet: So how're you feeling about kids these
days?
John: I really want a baby. But where would
we put one, Hank? Where are we going to fit
a baby inside this apartment? Are we going
to put it under the bed? I wanna have a baby.
I wanna have a baby a lot; babies are adorable.
I wanna have like sixteen of 'em, I want to
have like a little army of babies!
Puppet: In this space, create your own question
and answer it.
John: Puppet, the question is, "Pirates or
Ninjas?" Ninjas! I just like how fast they
strike.
Puppet: What does ambrosia taste like?
John: You know what ambrosia tastes like?
It tastes like all the things you can't eat
on Weight Watchers. Cheeseburgers, sugar cookies,
regular freaking ice cream instead of, like,
ice cream that's made out of air and human
hope.
Puppet: If you were a cliché, what cliché
would you be?
John: A dark and stormy night.
Puppet: What's your least favorite part of
any given day?
John: I don't enjoy brushing my teeth.
Puppet: Do you enjoy science fiction?
John: I really like Kurt Vonnegut, um, and
I also am a big fan of the short stories of
Margo Lanagan.
Puppet: Cheese or chocolate?
John: Why did you just name two things I can't
eat anymore? God, that's so mean!
Puppet: What was your first concert?
John: I think it might have been The Cure,
in 9th grade with Davon Razor. I did like
The Cure a lot.
Puppet: Where would you live if you could
live anywhere?
John: North Carolina.
Puppet: Would you prefer invisibility or time
travel?
John: Well, as you can see I already have
the gift of invisibility; I'm wearing my invisibility
cloak right now, so I guess I would choose
time travel.
Puppet: If you could start a business that
would be instantly successful, what would
it be?
John: A Malaria curing business? A We Only
Sell Novels by John Green Store? Anyway, I'm
not sure what the store would sell necessarily,
but it would definitely be called The Blind
Assassin in Your Pants. I'm sorry, I- I can't
stop myself. Thanks to all the commenters
for their great ideas.
Puppet: What's wrong with the world?
John: I, I really think the big problem, is,
uh, people. You know, I mean puppets are a
small problem, puppet; I'm, I'm not going
to let you guys off the hook entirely, but,
but people... we're the worst.
Puppet: Can I put this survey on my webpage?
John: You may. Hank, I'll see you on Monday.